[Applause]
[Music]
we're gathered here to show support for
our friend who was one fully convicted
and imprisoned for 30 days just for
partaking in a protest and we have
nothing to do with sad protest
we're all here to support our friend
[Applause]
here today because a friend from school
was arrested because he entered the
building of a public television bring in
the POTUS and she was she's now a month
in jail and she was arrested at his home
and he's barely 18 and this isn't right
and this isn't how I used to decide
what's right if something is legal that
doesn't mean it's right so we are here
to protest that and we are we're not
part of the other protesters just here
to support our friend and to say
something about that
[Applause]
you